you know what I hate about online anime
discourse you could be riding high off
the back of watching your favorite show
you could be expressing why you love it
so much and inevitably you'll get
someone chiming in with a comment like
chill out it's not that deep Bro like
there are most certainly ways of
overintellectualizing our favorite
stories and hey if your relationship
with a movie ends with the credits then
more power to you but I think the idea
that there's nothing more to discuss
Beyond General momentto moment content
is a real disservice to well all of
fiction really if all that mattered were
those plot beats then I'm sure a work
like one piece wouldn't be held up as a
once in a generation type story let
alone one its fans painstakingly dissect
so I guess what I'm saying is it
actually is that deep Bro